pour garder la maire monsieur
vous voulez vous que je passe d'autres
on est bien loti sait vous charmer
encore on doit bien que c'est votre
première saison
s'il est oui
phase one
j'ai vu tous les déserts c'est ce qui
m'a fait plus où j'ai vogué sur les mers
et je me suis emmêlé les aurores
boréales
moi ça m'a laissé froid au fond c'est
bien normal car il ya du feu chez moi et
je vous dis non
mais non mais non non non non non non
non non non non non non non tout ça ne
vaut pas
clair de lune à maubeuge
tout ça ne vaut pas
le doux soleil de tourcoing quoi quoi
quoi quoi tous à nouveau
une croisière sur l'amour e
tout ça
ou pas
à
des vacances au kremlin
bicêtre
hauts c'est fou ce que vous dansez bien
mademoiselle vous est une habituée de la
salle waterloo 1
je suis allé aux fraises je suis revenu
pontoise gfu filer à l'anglaisé avec une
tonkinoise egeler débarquées d'un bateau
mouche à quai c'est parce que j'ai fait
des bêtises à cambrai et je vous dis non
mais non mais non non non non non non
non non non non non tout ça ne vaut pas
[Musique]
à clair de lune à maubeuge
tous un niveau bas
au soleil de tourcoing
tout ça ne vaut pas
une croisière sur l'amour
tout ça nos pas
des vacances au kremlin bicêtre
vous n'avez jamais pris vos vacances
dans le nord
si vous connaissiez maubeuge
j'ai connu le grand amour dans des pays
lointains j'ai murmuré toujours sans en
être certain j'ai gagné des fortunes aux
quatre coins du monde j'ai joué jusqu'à
2 tonnes pour les yeux d'une blonde
'umich' vous dit non
mais non mais non non non non non non
non non non non non non tout ça ne vaut
pas
tout revers de l'unam on veut
je
tout ça ne vaut pas
le doux soleil de tourcoing
[Musique]
une croisière sur l'amour
tout ça ne vaut pas
des vacances au kremlin bicêtre
on va mademoiselle viendrai à mon gauche
[Musique]